[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today uh one of
the top YouTubers in America today or in
the world for that matter Graham Stefan
has become good friends with me and uh
through George I was good friends with
George long before that I've been
blessed to be on his show a couple times
and he's dropped by here once before and
they were in town so he and Jack and I
just um just did a version of his iced
coffee house and did I say that right
iced coffee hour hour iced coffee money
happy hour be in the house but there we
go yeah so if you don't know who Graham
is you need to check him out $130
Million worth of real estate he has sold
in his life he does a YouTube channel on
finance and on real estate and it's a
lot of fun to check out Graham Stefan be
sure and do that and uh they had last
month they had about 100 million viewers
on all of their various forms of Tik Tok
and everything else and 4 and a half
million subscribers on YouTube so uh if
you don't know know who he is it's CU
you're not in that format and that's the
only way it's possible you're not that
HP all all of us who hang out anything
around that know who Graham Stefan is
welcome back thank you so much for
having me back on so good to have you so
first question because you're you you
and I both share this huge love of real
estate and these interest rates ticking
up highly unusual across the landscape
of the last 20 years MH um uh are you
seeing what are you seeing out there
slowdown uh prices what are you seeing
it's defin slowed down a lot so what
I've noticed a lot of the smart money it
seems to be either buying real estate in
cash or they're waiting on the sidelines
and I think a lot of people look at real
estate from an investment standpoint and
think why would I buy real estate today
making a six to maybe 7% return When I
could use the same money to buy
treasuries without any work any risk at
5 a half% and there seems to be a
Tipping Point right now where where
deals are very difficult to come by
there's a lot of competition and sell
Ellers are locked in to these very low
mortgages they have very little
incentive to sell if they have a
mortgage that's 4% why would they sell
and replace that with a seven or 8%
mortgage it doesn't make a lot of sense
yeah consum investors aside consumer to
Consumer seem to be having that
discussion oh absolutely they're saying
yeah I could sell my house the price is
still really good but then I got to go
buy a house at 3x or 4X the interest
rate and yeah I could refinance it later
but they're really not thinking that way
they're thinking
I'm just going to wait on this a minute
yeah well I think 60% of mortgages right
now are locked in 4% or less substantial
yes that's almost all of them you I mean
that's the amount number below 2% is
bizarre yeah that's out there so cool
stuff so uh stock market's doing well
yeah like you said the treasury is there
but that's the little secret everybody
in the media the mass media in
particular is talking real estate and
failed to mention that the S&P in the
last 12 months has done about what 16
18% about that at the peak it was up
almost
20% yeah wow and that's just the S&P I
mean that's just if you just bought an
index fund which people do with their
eyes closed right you don't think that's
that's a Nob brain no thought thing if
you actually invested and thought about
it and studied a little bit you could do
better than that yeah and Graham I'm
curious a lot of your videos of course
for YouTube we have to be a little
salacious right there has to be a little
Doom and Gloom to get the people to
click but what are your real thoughts
when it comes to the economy what's
going happen in 2024 where do you think
things are heading are you been dooming
and glooming on your YouTube you because
otherwise people don't click that my
videos I like to be pretty unbiased I
like to the fact present the entire
picture let people come to their own
conclusions but if you don't make a
somewhat negative title no one will the
videos itself usually are pretty
positive overall but you have to lean
into that because otherwise people just
don't pay attention but you seem like an
optimistic guy you know just talking to
you you are very optimistic about the
future about finances where the economy
is going and you're invested in the
stock market and real estate yeah well I
think you could do well regardless of
how the economy does I think that's a
component of it and it might be a bit
short term in terms of the next few
years I have no idea what could happen
everything that I would think is going
to happen turned out opposite I would
have no prediction in terms of what
might happen but I think longterm uh I
believe in myself my ability to make
money I think for most people they have
a lot more Direct Control than they
think and you're betting on the American
economy term I think so and of course I
diversify I have international exposure
as well but it's a small component but I
do think that's important yeah the the
interesting thing is is that people get
confused between
investing and
speculating speculating is a purchase
that you're going to turn fairly quickly
it does it's not an evil word it's just
not investing investing always involves
a longterm time Horizon and when you're
investing with a long-term time Horizon
let's call it five years or more 100% of
the time I'm comfortable with the stock
market oh it's down then get in it's on
sale you know 100% of the time I'm
comfortable with the real estate market
well I don't know five years from now
you're going to not be doing that you're
going to be glad you bought a property
you know so a long-term time Horizon
like you said uh to me it it just
Smooths everything out and change you
know then you've got historical track
records and things start to kick in do I
know what it's going to do between now
and this time next year so I could do a
flip no that would scare the crud out of
me that's why a lot of home builders
aren't building specs right now
yeah they can't they can't you can't
predict it I mean economists and weather
forecasters the only people can be wrong
half the time and keep their job right
absolutely and then you could be right
once and you're genius you're genius
that was my one thing you could write
three books yeah well I'm curious grahe
you're getting married next year yes
it's very exciting this I didn't know
you didn't know this got congratulations
I thought we I thought you knew about
this break no you did not break I'm you
were asking Dave in an interview earlier
which little teaser there about you know
his relationship with his wife Sharon
and marriage is there anything you're
curious about kind of maybe nervous
about when it comes to finances and and
combining those not really Macy and I
are pretty attuned when it comes to
money uh and she's naturally very frugal
like yeah and to some degrees I would
say it's it's a good balance because
I'll certainly go out I don't fret
anymore of like going to dinner and
spending $100 on the bill whereas like 5
years ago that would be like well if I
spent $100 here I could cut back $100
over here and then it balances out and
if I if I skip this over here then I
could I don't do that anymore so I've
I've really come Le to enjoy your money
a little bit yes yeah to I'm still
Frugal but not to the same degree that's
when he got married ah now now lightened
up a little bit it lightened up a bit
just a little bit a little bit so you
and Macy are both tight wads and so
later you'll make little tight WS this
is great it's going to be this is great
A bunch of cheap skates what are you
willing to splurge on these days as
you've started to like let go of some of
that and enjoy it a little more I would
say experiences or something that in the
past I would usually forgo that to work
more so I would say
experiences uh I would say dinners are
something that I've really been enjoying
and going out to eat a few times a week
and I would say saving time which is
something that I've never really done
spending money for time saving
conveniences if I could uh like for
instance if I get a nicer seat on the
airplane but that means that maybe I
could work a little bit better if I have
a slightly larger seat I could I could
put my computer in front of me and if I
could get something else done I see that
as a justifiable expense so there's
certain things that I could do to save
time well if you need any tips on
spending ask Dave he's really good at
enjoying his money he loves experiences
he's traveling all over the world so
that's part of it is you know give save
spend you got to have balance so what's
the biggest advice with you having the
one of the largest YouTube channels on
real estate and money in the world today
what's the biggest piece of advice in
this current environment you've got for
folks listening I think it really just
depends on what their objective is I
mean my big thing is always save as much
as you can spend less than what you make
I think those are just important
qualities to have in terms of career
though because that's where I've really
gotten the biggest benefit is just the
channel and the Outreach uh the savings
certainly helped but the income that I
made from that was certainly a big
Catalyst but I truly loved what I do and
I still do it's like to me work never
felt like work it was always something
fun and that's where things came really
easy for me and I feel like if people
could find what they truly love to do
where it doesn't feel like work to them
and they could spend all day doing it
that's how you typically will succeed in
areas where others just can't keep up
that's your unfair Advantage I think
you're more creative you're more
energetic and you have to watch cuz you
work all time it's fun oh yeah it's fun